it can ask you i don't know if you know
who michael malus is but um
in terms of constructing systems of
incentives it's it's interesting to ask
i don't think i've talked to you about
this before
malice espouses anarchism so he sees all
government as fundamentally
getting in the way or even being
destructive to
collaborations between human beings
thriving
what do you think what's the role of
government in a society
that um
that thrives
is anarchism at all compelling to you
as a system so like
not just small government but no
government at all
yeah i don't see how this would work
the government is an agent that imposes
an offset on your reward
function on your payout matrix so it
your behavior becomes compatible with
the common good
so the argument there
is that you can have
collectives like governing organizations
but not government like where you're
born in a particular
set of land
and therefore you must follow this
uh uh rule or else
you're forced by what they call violence
because there's
there's an implied violence here so what
government the the key the key aspect of
government is
is it uh
protects you from the rest of the world
with an army
and with with police right so there's
this
it has a monopoly on violence it's the
only one that's able to do violence
there are many forms of government not
all governments do that right but we uh
find that in the in successful countries
the government has a monopoly on
violence
and
that means that you cannot get ahead by
starting your own army because the
government will come down on you and
destroy you if you try to do that and in
countries where you can build your own
army and get away with it some people
will do it right in these countries is
what we call failed countries in a way
and uh you if you don't want to have
violence the point is not to appeal to
the moral intentions of people because
some people will use strategies if they
get ahead with them that feel a
particular kind of ecological niche so
you need to destroy that ecological
niche and if a
affective government has a monopoly on
violence it can create a world where
nobody is able to use violence and get
ahead right so you want to use that
monopoly on violence not to exert
violence but to make violence impossible
to raise the cost of violence so people
need to get ahead with nonviolent means
so the idea is that you might be able to
achieve that in an anarchist state
with companies so with the with the
forces of capitalism
is
create security companies
where the one that's most ethically
sound rises to the top basically it
would be a much better representative of
the people because there is uh
less sort of stickiness to the the big
military force sticking around even
though it's long overlived
outlet so you have to use groups of
militants that are hopefully officially
organized because otherwise they're
going to lose against the other groups
of militants and they are coordinating
themselves with the rest of society uh
until they are having a monopoly on
violence how is that different from the
government i listen
so it's basically converging to the same
thing so i think it always i did my as i
was trying to argue with malice i feel
like it always converges towards
government at scale
but i think the idea is you can have a
lot of collectives that are
you basically never let anything scale
too big
so
one of the problems with governments is
it gets too big in terms of like the the
the size of the group over which it has
control
my sense is that would happen anyway in
in this so successful company like
amazon or facebook i mean it starts
forming a monopoly over
over entire populations
not over just hundreds of millions but
billions of people so i don't know
but
there is something about the abuses of
power the government can have when it
has a monopoly and violence right
and so that's that's a tension there but
so the question is how can you set the
incentives for government correctly and
this mostly applies at the highest
levels of government and we because we
haven't found a way to set them
correctly we made the highest levels of
government relatively weak
and this is i think part of the reason
why we had difficulty to coordinate the
pandemic response and china didn't have
that much difficulty
and there is of course a much higher
risk of the abuse of power that exists
in china because the power is largely
unchecked
and
that's basically what happens in the
next generation for instance imagine
that uh we would agree that the current
government of china is largely correct
and but never limit and maybe we don't
agree on this but if if he did uh how
can we make sure that this stays like
this and if you don't have checks and
balances uh division of power
it's hard to achieve you don't have a
solution for that problem
but the abolishment of government
basically would remove the control
structure from a cybernetic perspective
there is an optimal point in the system
that the regulation should be happening
right where you can measure
the current incentives and the regulator
would be properly incentivized to make
the right decisions
and change the payout metrics of
everything below it in such a way that
the local prisoners dilemmas get
resolved right you cannot resolve the
prisoner's dilemma without some kind of
eternal control
that emulates an infinite game in a way
yeah i mean there there's a sense in
which it seems like the reason
government
the parts of government that don't work
well currently
is because there's not good um
mechanisms
for um through which to interact for the
citizenry to interact with government is
basically it uh
it hasn't caught up in terms of
technology and i think once you
integrate some of the digital revolution
of being able to have a lot of access to
data be able to vote on different ideas
at a local level at all levels at the at
the optimal level like you're saying
that can resolve the the prisoner
dilemmas
and to integrate ai to help you out
automate things that are like
um
that don't require the human ingenuity
i feel like that's that's where
government could operate that well and
can also
break apart the inefficient
bureaucracies if needed there'll be a
strong incentive to
to um
to be efficient and successful so out
human history we see an evolution and
evolutionary competition of modes of
government and of individual governments
is in these modes and every nation state
in some sense is some kind of organism
that has found different solutions for
the problem of government
and you could look at all these
different models and the different
scales at which it exists as empirical
attempts to validate the idea of how to
build a better government
and i suspect that the idea of anarchism
similar to the idea of communism
is the result of
being disenchanted with the ugliness of
the real existing solutions and the
attempt to get to
an utopia
you